don't bring anyone love into this is
there anything else I want to do would
you rather oh okay would you rather let
me see what I have I have to pee so bad
okay drink the top layer your sister
take in the face vinegar strokes the
grandmother walks in on you masturbating
never have
[Music]
all right I'll say this before we get
started with would you rather z-- you
have a gift for these you really do you
come up with some of the best ones ever
thank you you like that it's amazing
yeah it's because I understand suffering
and no I feel like I I feel like I like
what is misery the would you rather
champ
thank you guys please let's go okay okay
would you rather yeah I like would you
rather wear a fart helmet
what's a fart helmet it's my own design
so a fart helmet is it's a tube that's
hooked up to your butthole and then it's
connected to like a space helmet like
what you wear like a mask yeah so a fart
mask oh they did okay so but every fart
it's in your face and you're smelling it
all day are you smelling your own farts
all day all day or or you pee in a mason
jar but you carry it with you everywhere
and you're like you have to you have to
talk about not to talk about it so like
you meet people you're like this is my
urine I believe in keeping all of it I
can get you a jar if you would like and
introduce you to the lifestyle right or
just smell your own fart with a mask on
right do you realize that like as crazy
as you look to people when you're like
this is my urine if you walk into the
bank with your fart mask on it's just
they're pressing the button under the
desk immediately right right well then
that's what I'm saying is that either
scenario it's a life ruiner you know
they definitely ruin your life yeah
that's your love with these i I just
think about what would be the most
horrible shit in the world yeah like a
fart helmet it's gonna it's a mask right
it's hard to perform it's
hard to perform your stand-up career is
over
like you can't call the club make sure
you have the mic inside my mask so I
don't miss any farts while I'm up there
no they won't they won't hook you up
with that yeah but you could put your
urine mason jar down well then that
disqualifies you from a lot like imagine
happening to Conan and then in your leg
he's like what's that time and then I
tell him he's like we'll be right back
it's like well interesting you should
ask it's pretty awful but I still think
you have some chance you know like some
people would not notice your mason jar
some people would be like okay and kind
of you know I mean kind of move move on
I think you have to go Masons you're a
fart mask is 100 percent you got you
should have tinfoil on your head too
like you you can't no one's gonna talk
to you but you say helmet but you're
describing a mask it's over your your
face is concealed and then when people
are like are you scared about the
apocalypse you like noir huh
I have a fart tube going from the my ass
to my mouth and they're like I'll see
you later and he's walking away so 100%
mason jar yeah I'll take the mason jar
too
it's happened exactly you have a story
and then they're like can absolutely the
essence of it is you have to tell people
like I've decided to do this thing
I collect my urine yeah you have to
that's the craziness and then I go have
you ever read a urine enema and then
they're like you have to you have to
preach the gospel the exit over there if
you don't mind yeah all right what do
you got I'm gonna take I'm gonna take
the mason jar mason jar okay clap for me
what's a mason jar
[Applause]
and the fart helmet Wow some nasty-ass
girls in the crowd how could you what
you like your own brand but your job is
over there's no way your boss is like
it's cool you work from home do you have
are you in a relationship you're married
you're have your are you single what
yeah it's yeah that could be your career
if you're like I wear my mask you sure
you could incorporate this into your
website and now you're making even more
money you just said that so sincerely
yeah I know
well now I'm thinking like she's
thinking you're working from home now
you've got fart helmet mister Escom it's
fucking brilliant dude it becomes a
lifestyle it's a Brandon okay yeah
alright next moving along here's my
second one okay okay okay
would you rather would you rather be
vegan but you're one of those vegans
that you have to fucking talk about it
24/7 that's what they do
yes just right now I wanted to be
respectful I'm sure there's a few that
are not proselytizers but you're the
annoying kind okay right and you're
constantly proselytizing every time
someone is with you like I hope those
shoes are leather and so you can vagina
right and you talk about your smoothies
all the time like bees are suffering
when you eat honey and yeah yeah and
you're one of those annoying people it
doesn't eat anything on the menu so when
we go out you're always like if they're
dairy in that it's that lactose freeze
that gluten-free is a so like
all-you-can-eat is like five things
okay pain you sound like you're a real
fucking fun guy okay or you have to
listen to me
whistle constantly 100% cutting a meat
out of my life my honour per side I
fucking hate whistle whistle for them
whistle for them
it's terrible no no I'm already listen
no I'm not having any dairy tomorrow I'm
not no no that was terrible
I don't that was terrible so I that
would be rough though I mean what you're
proposing is really difficult that's
terrible I would eat there i annoy the
shit out of you or you annoy the shit
out of everybody that's yes area I would
miss that food for sure that's what's
fucked up but yeah but hearing you yeah
there's the thing is it's not the her
whistle is bad it's that it would be
constant it would be yeah but when even
when I hear the world-class whistlers
I'm still like will you'd knock that
shit off please yeah that's horrible
I hate when people do it indoors
you know like waiting in line at the
bank and the guys like you're like are
you fucking serious right now he's
asserting dominance that's what they're
doing
yes there's that territory it is the
psychological reason starting there this
is my territory
that's a fucking listen to me whistle
dish fuck I hate them I think you would
rather fucking go vegan they listen to
you open I would be a real asshole would
rather listen to Christina whistle all
day every day and who would rather go
vegan and listen to her way so it's kind
of close I'd be okay yeah okay I've
gotten one last one okay this is this is
more gross would you rather never floss
you're done flossing some of you pigs
aren't doing it already okay yeah
or when you dump you're only allowed to
wipe once the conscious person Wow Wow
heated debate in here look this feels
like like a period piece yeah they're
like we're gonna allow women in the
workforce then I know it was like what's
going on that was such a sincere
reaction I know like whoa lady whoa
take a big stinky shit after I go I
don't use toilet paper I flush the
toilet I dip my hand I get in here three
rub clean and flush again and one two
three four five he's nasty as hell one
wipe I your dude you'd be yeah these are
great questions okay
yes order order here here Your Honor I
submit to the court that in this
particular scenario we are dealing with
bidet les toilettes
[Applause]
[Laughter]
order goddamn it order is absolutely
brilliant would you rather you will
entertain these thoughts this Triple D
slut wife has a point that's the thing
the reason I choose a bidet less toilet
is because this is the everyman scenario
hold on hold on hold on what you what
you propose is so absurd not if I
actually forgot what the other option is
what in the hell was the other other
know flossing no flossing no you are you
are 5150 if you choose one wipe over not
flossing again are you out of your guy
hold on I'm gonna revise it in the
moment because I feel there's a better
option than the flossing would you
rather have one wipe yes or not wash
your hands for a year and that's a
better would you rather
you could do that you could do that
again you would be hey there's that
fucking psycho that wears gloves
everywhere but it's better than being
like hey here's that guy that smells
like fucking piles of shit because he
listens to a podcast now Jana Jana yes a
way around such a conundrum of the one
WAP is to take a shower every time you
make a bowel movement that's the that's
the workaround if you will appeal denied
that is not acceptable that is not
acceptable
so oh no no this is this is not the same
now listen if you do the one wipe okay
this is you can wash your hands as much
as you like now that's the caveat so you
can one meaningful wipe goes a long way
hey there are some shits I take that
only require one way now get the fuck
out here what are you thinking Tom uh I
mean if you don't wash your hands for a
year right yeah you're fucked in a lot
of ways I mean you really are think
about all the time oh that's not crazy
I'm taking a shower shower yeah this did
you write this gentleman you bring up a
valid point what's the point why don't
you do the work okay
you may put plastic baggies over your
hands in the shower okay till to wash it
look you ever have a cast on your arm
and you have to cover it yeah you can do
that what sweetie
I can't hear you there's there's there's
that's what the Supreme Court would hear
what is it how are you gonna wash your
asshole if you can't get your hands okay
I cover them in play I cover them in
plastic baggies they're air types it's
so serious and that you all have a
washcloth which I'm opposed to using in
regular life but because of this thing I
have to and I washcloth my asshole
easy-peasy dude ya fuckin loofah that
shit dude no plastic bags no no yeah
yeah that's true oh there you go you're
suggesting what a fucking would you
rather I mean this is Charlottesville
all over again
this is crazy very divisive issue very
device are you choosing hand wash races
and washing or one wipe tom coburn
Tom what's your answer final answer we
need it I think what I think one wipe
calm yeah I thought I would definitely I
would be the gnarly hands dude I would
just walk around with unwashed hands I
cannot be one wipe guy you gotta be
kidding me
there would be times there would be
times when you're like I just can't jump
in the shower and you could not I could
not go through life like why you
shrugging like whatever because there
there are many one white but you can
shower after so that's why I'm saying no
what's that
Teesha what what happens to demos he
scoops with that all right this is
getting haven't seen in years
all right look look at all the fucking
alright let's fucking take a vote
yeah let's think about okay who votes
for they know hand-washing for a
one-year go ahead club who votes for one
wipe dumps do you hear that sounded like
that sounded like more women did the one
wipe dump I think is our shits are not
as Nylund
[Music]